the og crypto derivatives platform
and the best place to buy your bitcoin
hey guys and welcome back to the leia hill punch
show today we have a brilliant conversation and
we're talking about something which i've actually
never spoken about before we are talking about
bitcoin and healthcare pretty wild so make sure
you stick around um now before we do get into this
um i do want to let you know that it is sponsored
by um bitmex the og crypto derivatives exchange
they now actually have a spot exchange
for you to buy and sell your crypto
especially in a bear market with this kind of
volatility that we're seeing you need a name
that you can trust and bitmex sets the standard
for reliability performance and transparency and
of course has proven itself through multiple
market cycles and has stood the test of time
so very important and with all the volatility that
we have right now and they're actually giving away
um 1 million in usd prizes um to anybody that gets
involved with the bitmex spot exchange so all you
have to do to enter is trade the equivalent of 250
so if you do want to buy the dip it's probably a
good place to buy the dip so you can actually um
grab some bitcoin during the crash and um yeah try
and enter into that you can actually enter up to
25 times and one lucky winner will even receive
500 000 in bitcoin so i'm gonna leave the uh the
description and everything that you need the links
and everything like that in the description below
so take a look um and maybe try win yourself some
bitcoin um up to five hundred thousand and one
million dollars that's pretty cool um okay guys
so like i said we are talking about bitcoin and
healthcare um money and therefore the central
banks really are at the center of everything
so i'm so excited today to bring on andy
schunover the ceo of crowdhealth let's bring andy
on andy welcome to the show how you doing good
thanks for having me it's so good to have you um
like i mentioned this is a topic that i've never
spoken about before um i think you know people
throw out the term bitcoin fixes this and often
it's quite cringy um but apparently there's a
way that bitcoin does help the um the medical
and healthcare system um so let's just start by
you introducing yourself um and explaining how
you got into healthcare and bitcoin yeah
sure so um i've been in healthcare for
about 15 years started doing healthcare by called
remote patient monitoring so we had a company that
was monitoring folks with chronic conditions out
of their home so if you had diabetes let's say
we would be monitoring your glucometer and if your
blood sugar spiked then we'd say okay something is
going on here let's get involved so we had a call
center of lots and lots of nurses who are watching
that information to try to keep you from going
into the hospital sold that company back in 2014
and in the united states i know
you're abroad but in the united states
we have most of us have health insurance
through our company but since i sold my
company i didn't have health insurance anymore
so i thought that i could go to healthcare.gov
which is a marketplace here that's basically
standardized by the government to help people
get health insurance and so i went and got health
insurance from my wife and my two girls and it was
1200 bucks a month and it was an 8 000 deductible
which means i'm paying 1200 bucks a month and then
the first 8 000 of any of our health expenses so
i'm a good 20 what is that 22 grand in before the
health insurance company pays pays anything and uh
i just had a bad bad experience where my my little
one was having recurring ear infections and the
doctor said she needed to get tubes in her ears so
he did that and the health insurance came back and
said they weren't gonna pay for it so the surgery
was eight thousand dollars it was 15 minutes
so eight thousand dollars in 15 minutes i mean
i kind of joked that we would all love that
hourly rate right um and so i was like at that
point i was like man screw this like if you're
not going to pay for my health care then um
i'm not i'm not interested in doing this and
so i've actually been uninsured for the last
at least two years probably two and a half
years um and it's been been awesome um it's
been a free a pretty freeing thing i i also joke
that over the last two years i've ditched health
insurance and i have bought bitcoin which to me
are two of the most freeing things that you can do
in in the united states that is so crazy i'm so
excited to get into this i just i can't believe
the way um the healthcare is in the u.s i've been
reading a lot about it i've been asking um quite
a lot of different people because i've seen you
we were going to have this conversation um and it
really it blows my mind because we complain about
it in the uk um but we can see a doctor for free
we can see a doctor on the same day for free we
can get private medical cover for for 70 pounds
um a month and that covers everything there's
no there's no like you know you need to get in
a car accident nearly die pay 20 grand and
then you get insured and then you get cover
it blows my mind yeah yeah and i think
that um it's one of those things where
you you can choose cost quality and time that's
kind of like the triangle that you have to deal
with right if you want something that is low
cost you're either gonna have to pay a lot for
it or you're gonna have to wait a long time to
get it um and you know here in the united states
it's you know pretty high quality very high cost
but we can step in and and see you know provider
you know right away and the the rip against other
plans you know can canada has a socialized system
the uk has a socialized system is that you know it
takes a while to get into see some of those those
specialists um and that's sometimes the case and
sometimes not the case i mean i think the question
more um you know plainly is do you want
the government involved in your health care
right and you know i talked to a lot of bitcoiners
and most of them say no i talk to other bitcoiners
and a lot of them are like yeah well you know
it's way way cheaper so why not i mean i think
you can make a really good argument here that
if you don't want the government involved in
your dollar your money then you probably don't
and you really truly want to be a sovereign
you know individual then you probably should
wouldn't want the government being involved in
in choosing what you can or cannot
consume in terms of of health care
myself and being able to choose what i want
to consume and what i don't want to consume
there's this kind of overarching view at
least through you know the left and through
pro-government folks is that we're not smart
enough to make decisions about our own health care
and so we need others to tell us how to do it i
just don't believe that you know i don't believe
that that that should be the case um and sure we
should rely on doctors to help us make decisions
but ultimately they should be you know our
decisions and not the government's decisions
on what what type of health care we should be
able to consume yeah absolutely for those who
are just tuning in now um we're basically talking
about bitcoin and healthcare um and how andy
um is uh he started this company called crowd
health and crowd health are essentially um
merging bitcoin and healthcare together
so we're gonna try to figure out whether
uh bitcoin truly fixes the healthcare system
but before we go into that i really wanna just
sort of unpack like what is wrong with the um
with the healthcare system but before that um
you know you talk about being that sovereign
individual i'm intrigued what is it about bitcoin
and that you're interested in you know why didn't
you think about making something with um i don't
know ethereum or what other cryptocurrencies
like why did you want to mix healthcare with
bitcoin of all things yeah and so you know one of
the big ways that health insurance works is that
i put my premiums in every month like i said with
me and my my family i was putting 1200 in every
month and i didn't see it right it disappeared it
went to this black hole of health insurance land
and in essence what the health insurance company
does is they have this big pool of of dollars
you know sitting in a bank account it's called
a risk pool so that if anybody has a really big
health event they'll be able to use that risk pool
to pay for that health event the problem with that
is that that pool of dollars is melting you know
we had 9.1 percent inflation you know last month
that pool of capital is is is going down in terms
of value and therefore to replenish it you have to
pay more into that pool of capital and so with
healthcare not only do we have an inflationary
impact that we're seeing especially over the
last six months we're also seeing a systemic
inflation uh because of government regulation that
over the last three decades healthcare prices has
have gone you know through the roof so we have
these two inflationary impacts on that pool of
capital that said hey hold on a second here if we
can pay for healthcare in a different way we get
rid of the systemic inflation if we can hold that
pool of capital in bitcoin as opposed to dollars
then you get rid of the in the money supply issues
that that are driving inflation you get rid of
both of those and you really can disrupt the way
that health care is being paid for in this country
and so that's why bitcoin was so interesting to
me and in fact i was talking to jimmy song who
i know you know many of the people watching
this he's a friend of mine i live in austin
and we were at lunch and i was telling him
about my fiat version of this and he's like dude
andy if you can do what you're doing in the
fiat and introduce bitcoin into this you will
have you know a killer you know service because
you're getting rid of that money supply inflation
um and that's what really turned me on to it so i
got orange pill by jimmy and my business model is
way way better since i got to incorporate bitcoin
that's really cool we'll get into all of that um
so but you know you talk about um the price going
up um you mentioned inflation um but overall i
just i just can't attribute the medical uh system
in the us to inflation obviously so can you break
down for us you know why it's such a mess i mean
somebody just by the way wrote in the comments
now in france it's only one euro and i know they
have crazy taxes there but you have crazy taxes
here in the u.s anyway yeah yeah um so the reason
why it's so screwed up in the united states is
um the the buyers of health care are health
plans so they're the ones that are ultimately
paying for your health care if i were to go and
slip and tear my acl you know and i had health
insurance the health insurance company would
be the one that is paying for that health event
they have a contract with the local hospital
they have a a rate that has been agreed upon
they're the buyer okay the seller of health care
or big hospital systems and so we have this crazy
thing in the united states where if i put if i
pay a thousand dollars per month to the health
insurance company they can only make 150 off of me
in profit and administrative costs okay and so um
so for them to make their their profit generating
you know organizations and so for them to get more
profit the only way they can do that is to have
my premium go up right so if they wanted to make
10 more 165 a month on me my premium would have
to go from a thousand to eleven hundred and fifty
dollars right um so they're actually incentivized
to make more profit and therefore incentivize to
see my rate go up every every month so the buyers
of healthcare are incentivized to see the price go
up the sellers of healthcare the hospital systems
they're the ones you know providing the services
they clearly want the price to go up they want to
get paid more for their service and so it's just
weird thing where it's so perverse the buyers
of healthcare and the sellers of healthcare
want the price to go up and therefore the price
is going to go up um you know it's it's not that
hard to understand when you kind of understand
the true incentives of these organizations
everybody wants the price to go up and therefore
that's what happens unfortunately and i think as
well um you know you talk about these incentives
but there's a lot of talk about corruption in the
uh medical industry um i'm interested um to hear
your take on that yeah there is i would say it's
probably five percent i mean it's not a lot
i mean there's there's corruption out there
um i i generally think that 95 of doctors who
are the ones who are ultimately kind of saying
hey this is what i with the medical procedure
i want you to to to do to to cure you whether
it be an injury or an illness they then
have to go to the health plan and say
please health plan will you allow me to
perform surgery on andy because he tore his
acl that health plan then can say yes they'll
pay for it or no they won't pay for it and so
um you know there there is a little bit of
corruption there it's not a ton it's it's probably
five maybe ten percent of the total cost in in the
country but it is it's not one that that massively
moves the needle one way or the other but i think
in that example the the important part of that is
it's not your doctor ultimately making the
decision it's the health plan ultimately
making the decision right and in the nhs or if
you're in medicare or in medicaid or whatever
it is the government ultimately making the
decision whether or not they're going to pay for
that service and that's one where i was like hey
let's take the big health insurance plan let's
take the government out of this and let it be
between you and your doctor and you all can decide
you know what you want to pay for
or not pay for for your your health
what about monopolies in the health care
industry um what what's going on there
that could potentially you know be pushing
these prices up yeah so i i live in austin
um we have two big health systems in austin it's
called st davids and ascension and if you think
about united healthcare one of the other big
health insurance providers coming to austin
they have to have those two health
systems because nobody is going to choose
united healthcare if they don't have both of them
they want access to all of those resources and so
you you basically have a duopoly in austin
negotiating against united healthcare and so
even if united wanted to negotiate against these
two hospital systems they can't you know i i make
a claim and i truly believe this that i have more
negotiating power with the local hospital system
than unitedhealthcare does which is i think the
seventh largest company by revenue on the planet
you know and so that's one of the benefits of
me buying my healthcare as opposed to united i
have more negotiating power than unitedhealthcare
does in getting a really good price for my for my
service um and and that's one of the challenges
that we we see with our current system is you've
got somebody who's supposed to negotiate on our
behalf who is not negotiating on their behalf
because they don't want to and they don't they
can't really negotiate on their behalf because
they're negotiating against the new duopoly
you have very concentrated power on both sides
which ultimately leads to just higher prices and
that's what's really screwed up our system so what
is crowdhealth how are you trying to basically
change that so kratos is basically an alternative
option for people in the u.s yeah you know so when
i um had that situation with my daughter and the
the health plan said that they they wouldn't it
was medically unnecessary and so they wouldn't
cover it i i spent the next two years um put
coming together putting together some tools
that said hey if i wanted to live outside the
health insurance space if i wanted to make my own
sovereign choices about what happens with me and
my family's healthcare then i gotta put you know
i gotta figure out how to do this right so we put
together some tools that allow us to to operate
effectively outside of of of health insurance and
so you know we have unlimited access to virtual
primary care physicians i could go on today
i can talk to a primary care physician about
whatever's going on with me i pay a certain
amount per month no incremental cost to doing
that really inexpensive which is awesome right i
have access to really low cost prescription drugs
which is great i take out the insurance plan
and what they call the pharmacy benefit manager
here in the united states which is the two primary
drivers of cost and i can go almost directly to
the drug companies and get much better pricing
than united healthcare can get even and then i
have this community of people that i'm a part
of so if i have a really big health expense
then these community people can pitch in to
andy's health expense so if i tour my acl the
health plan generally would be paying like twenty
thousand dollars twenty to twenty two thousand
dollars for that acl i can pay in cash twelve
thousand dollars um for that same um surgery so
what united healthcare will pay for twenty two
thousand i can pay twelve thousand dollars in cash
um so then the question is like how do i get cash
to pay for that not a lot of people have twelve
thousand dollars hanging around so in crowd health
what happens is is we got a community of people
i pay the first 500 crowd health goes out and
crowd funds the remaining 11 500 and i we do that
we've done that on in an average of three days um
so within three days you can get the remaining 11
500 to pay for your your acl um replacement or
your acl repair so we're saving you a ton of money
you're paying for it in cash um and it's just all
around a better system to be able to to do that
so how are you able to access um cheaper uh
surgeries yeah um and cheaper prescriptions
yeah so let's let's talk about the acl um yeah
if you got paid by a health plan you get paid 22
000 but you have to bill for that so um
i was talking to one orthopedic surgeon
he's got eight billers for every doctor right so
those eight billers are costly they're expensive
they also have to use their the software that they
use is the one that actually builds it and that
software takes another six or ten percent plus the
the the doctor spends about 30 percent of his time
dealing with health insurance so if he could get
that 30 percent back doing surgeries he could make
a lot more money yeah plus they don't get paid by
the health plan for 60 to 120 days i'm paying for
that that on the day of the surgery so all of
these things the doctors look at this and say
wow like i want to get paid in cash on the
day of of the surgery um and i will give you a
significant reduction in in doing that so for
all those reasons doctors when i talk to them
are the most excited about this because they
get rid of all of this administrative burden
um and get paid in cash on the day of the surgery
which they love so that's the core of how we're
able to do this is pay doctors in cash on the day
of the surgery and ultimately we'll pay them in
bitcoin via lightning on the day of the surgery
and my friction goes down even even more you
know that's we've done that before have you done
that i don't know not yet but it's version two of
what we're trying to do because you know we're
telling all the doctors that we're working with
hey can we pay you in bitcoin um and ultimately
they're gonna start saying yes and we're gonna
start doing it over with with bitcoin so it'll
be it'll be fun once we make that that step oh
i believe it um that's that's only 12 months away
for sure um that's that's really interesting um
so you know you talk about uh you putting down the
first five hundred dollars um and then um you know
you're gonna you're basically gonna raise i guess
11 500. so where are you getting that money from
yeah so um all of our members put in about 175
bucks a month every month into an account the
count is theirs and then when we try to crowdfund
for that 11 500 crowd health will go to all those
people and say hey you have 500 bucks in your
account you know when you use 50 of it to help
andy with his torn acl and then you have the
ability 50 bucks right you don't ask for much
no it's on average been about 50 bucks something
per person so if you have four people in your your
you know your family it's more than that but it's
on average about 50 bucks so you have 500 in your
account that you put in right i'm asking you to
use 50 of it to help andy and if you say yes then
i transfer 50 from your account to andy's account
if you say no then i move on to the next person so
um you know then the question is like okay
so why would i help andy you know with his
torn acl it's not like childhood leukemia
or something that's like tugs at your heart
we've got an internal system that says um you know
leia has been asked 10 times and she said no 9 out
of 10 times so leia is not a very good member
of the community and so when leia asks for um
others to crowdfund her health event we tell her
we say it's leia you're not in the united states
but if you were leia is from x state she has a
torn acl she has a reputation score of 1 out of 10
which means she's not a very good member of
the community and she's trying to raise 11
500 the probability that leia gets i'm picking on
you but you know what i'm saying the probability
that leia gets gets crowdfunded is really really
low because you haven't been a good member of
the community so there's a reciprocity engine
that generates people saying yes and wanting to
to give to the community but you can say no
if you don't want to and that's that's your
prerogative so you know i want it to be voluntary
um and and the great thing about that too is if
you say no and you leave crowd health the
money in your account is still your money
so we give that money back to you um it
doesn't go into an insurance company and
you never get to see it again it's actually
your money it's sitting in your account
and when you leave we take an account closing
fee but anything above that it's yours okay um
so well so where does bitcoin come into it you're
putting in 175 dollars a month um dollars into an
account and then what and then um if you're
a part of our bitcoin crowd um what we have a
group of just bitcoiners who you will be funding
other bitcoiners health expenses um and so um
two cool parts of this one is if you're part
of that crowd of the 175 bucks that goes in
um 75 or a little less than 75 percent is put
into bitcoin so we just announced that's a big
uh a partnership with swan bitcoin um we put it
into swan and then you you still have a little bit
of cash in your account so because we don't want
you to sell your bitcoin so you have cash in your
account you use that if i do crowdfunding and if
at any point you don't have any cash left in your
your account then you have an option you can
either sell your bitcoin or you can put a little
bit more cash into your account what we want
people to do is put a little bit more cash in your
account is leave your bitcoin there especially
at 22 000 or whatever it's at today right
um and so in essence what you're doing is you're
putting together your own little risk pool and
it's full of bitcoin so if you leave and bitcoin
goes from 20 000 to 400 000 like we think it will
you get all of that upside um all of that
appreciation of that bitcoin is yours um it's
not ours you know health insurance companies
will take your money and they'll invest it and
they get the profit of that no no you and you're
putting it into bitcoin and all that appreciation
of that bitcoin is yours so we don't have any
inflationary assets anymore you have bitcoin
and you're you're sharing your expenses with other
bitcoiners um and i was in miami you know what
a few months ago and as i'm walking around and
seeing these 20 000 peoples like these bitcoiners
are young they are in better shape than the
general population and so that's going to be the
community of people in which you're going to be
helping each other paying their their their bills
um and so you know it's a really good group of
people to be you know helping out because they
just don't have very high bills you know
it's injury related bills like you know
running or playing soccer or whatever it may be
sorry football where you are late i'm sure um
as opposed to like diabetes and obesity and and
cost related to that so you're in a group of
people who are taking their health care they're
taking personal responsibility over their own
health care which is the group of people that you
want to be involved with um so those are the two
kind of cool components of what we are doing with
bitcoin is you get to hold some of your money in
bitcoin and you're a part of a crew a crowd of
bitcoiners um and we we think that's pretty cool
so you're not joining a crowd of severely
overweight people who want to take no personal
responsibility for anything that they do eating
terribly i think bitcoiners absolutely they're
carnivores right they're carnivores they're all
they're all healthy folks or most that are anyway
no seed oils none of that right well and it's
it's true like i i mean these bitcoiners are
you know actuarially better off than than
the general population they take personal
responsibility for their own their own healthcare
you know and i think that's important too the
third component of a bitcoiners that i think is
a really cool characteristic is if you have a
system in which you think you're getting screwed
which is our current healthcare system we have a
a psychological component to this is i want
to take as much out of the system as possible
right i want to consume as much because i'm
getting screwed by the system whereas if you have
a system of people who are bitcoiners and you know
that if you try to take you know be a leech on the
system it's just impacting your other bitcoin
folks right like you're going to make better
health care decisions if you don't try to to
suck the system out as as much as as you can
right so there's a psychological impact here too
that just the consumption of resources goes down
because you know you're in a group of of
your people right like this is my tribe
um and we think that has a pretty big component
of reducing healthcare costs as well yeah no that
is really interesting and so you said 75 of
what you put in a month goes into bitcoin yes
that's it that's a that's an interesting
chunk it's not like a small amount so
whatever's left in fear that's essentially what
you would use to fund other people's procedures
yes that's right and and we've been going on
about a year now um and we have used some 25
of the money that people have put in for health
events um we think the bitcoin crowd is going
to use even less than that um and so we think
that 25 is the right number and you know at some
point if we have to you know increase it to 30
or 35 percent you're still putting in you know
65 or 70 percent of bitcoin so we want kind of all
the excess funds to be put in bitcoin and and um
you know we'll we might have to go up and down
based upon um you know how the the crew is doing
but again there's another incentive for people to
be like look let's not consume bad health care um
let's let's consume it wisely um and so we can
keep them as much as possible going into bitcoin
and as little as possible going into into fiat um
you know let me give you just a quick example of
this where you know we had somebody uh the other
day go and get get labs just their their annual
labs you know you go and get your blood drawn and
they went to a location where that those labs were
five hundred dollars we had we had a location
um like five minutes it was like two miles away
that we could have gotten the exact same labs
for 50 bucks so a 90 reduction in a five-minute
car ride right and so you know i think that
bitcoiners are the ones are like dude i'm not
gonna you know get scammed by this guy who's gonna
do 500 for something i can get for 50 and so you
know if you called if that person called us and
said hey where can i get my labs from we could
have told them there was a place two miles away
that you could have gotten your labs right and so
that's that's those are the decisions that you can
make around your health care that significantly
impact the cost of of health it's not a
consumption issue generally it is a price issue
so we can find a really good price um for you you
know almost anywhere you live in in the country at
a really high quality doctor if you just call us
and let us know that you're you're headed that way
so what exactly do you cover then because um
if it's a 500 uh you have to pay first 500
what if you just want to go see a doctor i don't
know if you have a sore throat or something like
how does that work yeah so if you want to go
see a doctor for a sore throat well that would
typically be an urgent care visit so you can go
on our app you know you just head to the app you
head urgent care and within two minutes you'll
be able to talk to a doctor and say hey i have
a sore throat what do you recommend they can
get you a prescription at the local pharmacy
you know within minutes you know i had a i had
a buddy you know five or six weeks ago he woke
up he didn't feel well he talked to an urgent care
doctor virtually over our app that urgent care got
doctor get him a six dollar prescription at the
local pharmacy and within because he thought he
had strep um he did and within 24 hours he
felt much better and he's like hardly even
had to leave his house um and it's like for us the
people in our 30s right low late 20s 30s early 40s
like i don't want to go to a hospital i don't want
to go to a doctor's office i want to do as much
virtually as possible and so you can talk to a doc
anytime you want virtually and it cost you nothing
that's all part of your membership and so that's
what we're trying to push people to to is say
hey talk to a doc virtually you don't have to go
anywhere to do that you know we can we can get you
nine times out of ten what you need without
actually having to go in and see the doctor
and you know what are they going to do you know
live anyway not not a whole lot like listen to
your heart i mean we can tell if our hearts racing
or not what if you need like what if you i don't
know what if like they need to see you or if you
have like a rash on your body or something like
how does that work yeah one of our initial one of
our initial uh uh health events over a year ago
was a rash that one of our actually employees had
who was on crowd health and so she went on urgent
care she took a picture of her the rash she you
know sent the picture to the doctor the doctor was
like it's either a b or c you know let's try one
and if it doesn't work or try the next and try the
next and after two visits she got it figured out
um and it was all done remotely and so if there is
and yeah totally yeah it was a part of her
membership um and so she didn't pay i don't i
don't think she hardly paid anything as a part of
that maybe just a little bit for prescriptions but
it was a i think it was you know a 50 prescription
or something like that so it wasn't that big of a
deal um even that 50 like this still blows my mind
because in the uk i don't think i've ever paid
more for a prescription than like eight pounds
i think prescriptions are eight pounds i think
there's like a cap on it but yeah but we're paying
national health insurance to compensate for that
that's a whole different story on prescriptions
like our government for some reason won't allow
our medicare to negotiate with the pharmaceutical
companies and so um you know we we pay in the
united states i think two or three times as
much as the next person pays for all of our
our prescription drugs and it's all the lobbyists
you know on behalf of the pharmaceutical companies
who are you know giving lots of money to
politicians um you know it is truly like a medical
industrial complex you know it's the lobbyists
are paying the politicians the politicians are
making rules the rules are impacting our health
care and increasing health care and until you can
you know get rid of the lobbyists um it's just not
gonna not gonna happen so it's a totally screwed
up system over here and has um and you're new
right how long have you said yeah one year yeah
so naturally anything that's new people might feel
like there's some risk there um so have you been
able to genuinely cover every single uh medical
issue that uh one of your members has brought up
every bill that has been submitted to us for
crowdfunding has been crowdfunded um and it's been
crowdfunded in three days or less and so um you
know we have a a group of things on our website
that you can go and take a look that we we will
not crowdfund for so you know any cosmetic stuff
we're not going to crowdfund for you know a
butt implant like just not going to happen
right we're not doing that yeah i hope not yeah
and so and you know and so the other thing is if
you have a pre-existing condition meaning you
have a condition before you join we want you
to be a good member of our community and and
and own your fair share of that and so you're
responsible for it for the first year right and
then in the second year we'll fund up to 25 000
of it fifty thousand dollars the third year and a
hundred thousand dollars a year in the fourth year
so if you have diabetes or something right you
would own the cost associated with that diabetes
in the first year and then we would start
funding it from the community in the second
third and fourth years and so we just don't have
a lot of people that have chronic conditions join
but we have a lot of people that have you know
high cholesterol high blood pressure things
like that because uh the the prescription drugs to
take care of that are are pretty inexpensive maybe
expensive to you but you know it's it's you know
40 or 50 bucks a month for high blood pressure
and high cholesterol type of medications and so
people are being like you know what i'm saving
several hundred dollars a month by joining crowd
health i will pay 50 bucks for my medications
knowing that in year two the the crowd will help
out with that that's so fascinating so if you
become ill for whatever reason you know and it's
not just a doctor now you know you you'd like to
go see an expert or whatever it is um i don't know
how much people charge in the us in the uk for
example um if you want to see like uh i don't know
an expert you'd pay let's say like 100 120 pounds
an hour to see a consultant um would you cover
that or not because it's under that 500 yeah so
for any injury or illness the first 500 bucks is
yours um so if you have you know my i'm going to
keep using my acl tear and i go to an orthopedic
surgeon that orthopedic surgeon is going to
charge you 250 bucks to see him um and you
probably will you know you'll have a couple
visits before you go so you'll be responsible
for that you'll you'll fund that first 500
and then anything above that 500 we will go out
and fund from the community um okay and so that's
how that works so yeah you're responsible for the
first 500 bucks of anything but here's the key to
that right is a lot of people will go to the er
right and you have no idea what it's going to cost
when you go to the emergency room you know you
can go to the emergency room and if you have a
five or six or seven thousand dollar deductible
um you're responsible for the first five six or
seven thousand dollars of that whereas with crowd
health if you go to the er it's gonna be greater
than 500 but you're going to pay the first
500 and then we're going to crowdfund the rest
so there is a bit of a peace of mind to say okay
you know i'm not going to get a hit up with a
10 000 bill that i'm going to have to pay i don't
have 10 000 in my my bank account this is going
to put me bankrupt and in fact 250 000 families
last year who had health insurance went bankrupt
due to a health care event and that to me is
what we want to get rid of is get rid of any
kind of bankruptcies related to health care and
in our year we've had zero so you know insurance
companies 250 000 you know crowd health zero is
so far as is the scoreboard this looks like a
pretty good school board it again it just blows my
mind like because i am somewhat of a libertarian
um so i do think you know it's down to the
individual um but being from the uk and having
the nhs has something always to fall back on um
when it comes to uh you know medical expenses is
just so different you know it's it's shocking
it's just shockingly different um and i hear
a lot of uh americans actually go down to south
america for um medical concerns yeah no and and
i've i've heard that as well i mean i
think the the the bottom line of this is
if you have a health care event like a really
expensive procedure that you have to have done
we will find you a place that can do it at a
reasonable price you know we had a guy uh you
know a couple months ago maybe three months ago
who had a health a heart problem in wisconsin
and his local hospital told him he was they
would do the procedure for 83 000 we found him
a hospital in the united states with a really good
surgeon for 20 thousand dollars okay so saved 75
he paid the first 500 we crowdfunded the remaining
19 500 and in addition to that he was in wisconsin
his doctor was in oklahoma we put him him and
his wife two first-class tickets to oklahoma
covered the flight the nicest hotel in oklahoma
city which was a you know four and a half star
hotel um for three nights paid for all of his
food and still saved i think it was like 55 000
or something like that versus you know what his
local hospital um was gonna charge him so that's
the price discrepancies that you can find in our
in our country which is is sad i mean oklahoma
city and wisconsin are only a thousand miles
apart and it's you know 75 percent different
that's that's how screwed up our system is yeah
that is absolutely insane it just blows my mind
um and i'm learning more and more about this um
since you know i work with mostly americans most
my friends are american now at this point so um
yeah i'm learning more and more about this and so
um i want to go back to the bitcoin aspect of it
for a second so it's 175 um it's 175 a month and
75 of that roughly goes into bitcoin how does it
go into bitcoin you mentioned swan like how does
that work yeah and so the the money that is in
your account gets transferred over to swan you
open a swan account when you join us as well um
and so you will have full access to that that that
bitcoin we don't even have access to it our name's
not anywhere on the account it's all your account
it is a custodian account i know that's not
perfect for all the maximalists out there but it's
one where it's like look it's it's in your
name it's in swan swan is a you know a
well-respected you know custodian and so we had to
do that for a variety of reasons um you know we're
actually working on is if you get a certain amount
of bitcoin in that swan that you can actually
off-board that into a cold wallet because there's
no need for you to hold you know 20 000 worth of
bitcoin and in swan like that that doesn't have
the impact that that we need it to have we need
a thousand or two thousand dollars so we're gonna
try to figure out how to off-board that onto a
cold wallet that you know then you have the keys
to that um and so we're working on that right now
but in essence what happens is is you're
gonna join crowd health today um and
after uh the first four months it's all
cash the fifth month it's 75 bitcoin 25
dollars and and there thereafter so
that's that's the way that that works
so you actually have two accounts that you set up
when you join us a bank account and a swan account
um so i'm gonna leave um all the information
in the description guys so if you do wanna
join crowdhealth i'm going to leave that
all for you in the description um after
the conversation um so if they do want to join by
the way just it's it's join crowdhealth.com leia
and if you do slash leia there's a special
promo code for anybody who um is listening to
this so make sure you put leia l-a-y-a-h and as a
promo code and you'll get that that special promo
what is the special primary it's 99 bucks as
opposed to that 175 for six months so you get
a significant reduction off of of what you're
paying and and here's why we're doing that is
what we found is when people join they have almost
no health events for the first three to six months
um especially the bitcoiners that we've seen
these are healthy people they're coming in and
they want to use our virtual docs which don't cost
the community anything we pay for that we pay 100
for that and so the costs are just so low over
that first six months that we're we're reducing
the cost um for for all the your listeners and
um so use leia as your promo code and so you and
if whatever reason people want to leave and you
know they say they every month they're putting in
175 or 99 or whatever it is every single month and
say they want to leave um they get that money back
basically any money that they haven't used
for crowdfunding so let's just say that i've
been around for ten months and i have you know
fifteen hundred dollars in my account and i've
used three hundred dollars of it for crowd funding
which means i have twelve hundred dollars left
um crowd health takes a 250 close fee because
we have to shut down your accounts and all that
kind of stuff and then you take the remaining
so i don't know what i don't remember exactly
what the math is but in that situation you would
take a thousand bucks back with you and we would
we would wire it back to your your personal
account um if you yeah for any of the money that
you haven't used for crowdfunding so that's one
of the huge benefits of this it's not like you're
just throwing money away it's still yours you
still have access to it and total control over it
yeah that is one of the most attractive things
about it because what freaks me out about the us
healthcare system is is it some in some ways
cheaper to just not get healthcare because like if
you're paying a thousand dollars a month right for
like two years twenty four thousand dollars and
then you have this one health scare or whatever
it is and you know you have to pay for it i mean
yeah it's cheaper to not do it we have 30 million
americans that don't have health insurance right
and so they have found and it's a lot of people
who are our age right late 20s to early 40s and
they're saying hey you know if i get hurt
i'll figure it out but i don't want to pay
you know 500 if you go to the healthcare.gov it's
400 bucks and then you have a 4 000 deductible
so i'm paying 4 800 plus i have to pay the next 4
000 it's like 10 grand so if i have any ill injury
or illness under 10 grand i'm better off being
uninsured and so i'm just going to take the risk
yeah yeah for us it's like you're putting
money into your account every month and yes
you're helping the the group um with some of
their big expenses but you're also going to
be helped with some of your big expenses right
we'll crowdfund that we'll help you crowdfund
that so i mean i think it's a perfect scenario
for folks in their you know 20 late 20s 30s 40s
and you know we have people having babies with us
i think we have 10 or 12 babies that are going to
be born here over the next five or six months
so it's good for that too um it's just i think
a great great opportunity for folks like like us
if you're in the states i'd get you to sign up
um but our average age is in the mid 30s so
that is the average age it's something like
36 or 37 is the last time that i that i when
i looked and something i wanted to ask you
which i forgot um so it's that 500 um premium
that obviously you have to pay um but say for
whatever reason you wanted to go see a specialist
in a certain area not just a doctor but an actual
consultant um would you be able to direct
to a consultant that would pay a lower cost
that would charge less sure yeah yeah for sure
and we and we have specialists internally um you
know a neuro specialist a cancer specialist those
kind of specialists that it's not we we outsource
it to another company but that is a part of um
if you were to come down with cancer today we
we have people wherever the wood is you don't have
any wood yeah that's what we say in english is
we can give you resources but again even the cost
of those resources to walk you through cancer
treatment that consultant that is all crowdfunded
so you know you're still if you get cancer today
you're paying 500 bucks we're gonna crowdfund
the rest of that for you um and again we don't
guarantee that we're gonna be able to crowdfund it
but so far you know over hundreds of bills we've
been able to crowdfund every single one so um we
don't promise that we'll get it crowdfunded for
you but we're we're pretty darn good at it and you
never touch the bitcoin it the the money comes out
of so if somebody needs to say 50 that would come
out of the 175. okay got it yeah we never touch
the bitcoin we don't have access to it we don't
see it it's yours um and so we don't we don't
uh we don't we can't touch the bitcoin yeah
no i listen i think it's really fascinating
um you know like i said i've been doing a lot
of research on the medical industry in the us
at the moment and uh yeah it's been um a learning
curve as a british person it's been fascinating um
so if people do want to join crowdhealth as their
medical insurance and medical cover um you know
how can they stay up to date how can they follow
you obviously like i mentioned i'm going to leave
a link in the description below and but you
know how can they get involved yeah and just
to clarify once we're not health insurance so we
are an alternative way to pay for your health care
join crowdhealth.com leia and that's you know
leia's personal landing page there so you'll have
find all the information there um joincrowdhealth
on twitter or schoonoverandy is my twitter twitter
account so um you can follow me there too
you we we usually put all of our news out
on twitter first given that's where our bitcoin
crowd is um most of the time uh so you'll if you
follow crowdhealth.org schoon over andy you'll
you'll get the latest that's great andy i want
to thank you so much for coming on um do you have
any last final thoughts you want to share with us
about bitcoin and you know really having a form of
medical cover which is just totally outside of the
government yeah i mean if you think if you really
want self-sovereignty you want to take control of
your money clearly we're all into bitcoin um i
got a significant amount of my worth in bitcoin
and if you don't want the the government uh
you know telling you what to do with your
money i don't think you want the government
telling you what to do with your body and so
um you know if you truly want to be self self
sovereign you know sovereign individual then
come on over to us and you can choose uh what
health care you know you want and don't want um so
we'd love for you all to join us andy thank you
so much for speaking with me it's so interesting
i love to hear um you know different people
and how they're sort of involving bitcoin
and whatever they're creating um so thank
you so much for coming on andy thanks leo
yeah absolutely and guys please don't forget to
hit the like button and hit the subscribe button
so you never miss a video and we will see you
all next week bye bye the leia high plan show